it's very very difficult to mature
until you have children
and
there are other ways of maturing but
it's hard and the reason it's hard i
think is because
you're not mature
until someone else
is more important than you
and
it's possible that that would happen
with your wife your husband
but not like with children well i've
been thinking about that so you know
we're about to have our first child in a
month and i've been thinking about that
a lot lately like it's just something
that's constantly stirring in my head
that i feel like i've sort of gotten to
the end
of where i can get
mature in my maturation process
not that i can't change or get better at
this or that or something but i do feel
like i'm at the end of one phase right
now i really i very
much feel that and i think i'm feeling
it more and more each day as we get
closer to august 22nd which is the due
date
you also told me dave when we were
talking about this before that you you
started to think about being older as
well and i suppose that
then that with your concentration on the
present and the lack of role models that
there was no real vision for what it
might be like to
well to grow old in the gay community i
suppose yeah and you know it's funny i i
the gay community i i hate that yeah
that phrase i know even even as you said
it it's like
it doesn't mean anything to me i don't
think of you as part of the straight
community you know it's just one of
these things we say these things we
don't even know exactly why we're saying
them but i didn't have that role model i
didn't have that there was no map there
really was brotherhood of the
marginalized exactly i guess that's a
group i could be part of i suppose in
some bizarre sense um but even that is
sort of nauseating i guess um but but so
we're on tour together and
david's texting me and we're going back
and we're talking on the phone and we're
face time and it just keeps coming up
and you keep talking about this on stage
and on top of everything else i'm
meeting all of the people that are
attending the shows and you know this
the amount of people that were in new
families or that the
wife was pregnant for the first time and
i'm seeing the joy on these people's
faces all of this is hitting me and then
you keep saying this thing that for most
people they have to do it but there are
these exceptions and i kept thinking
well wait a minute could i be the
exception that i could live a fully
actualized best possible life without
having kids and at the same time be
married to someone who wants kids that
then what am i even married for well
right right well that does beg that
question right so now these are these
things are really hitting each other
and because i had nev because the map
wasn't there the road map just wasn't
there i started going man i really have
to think about this now and i remember
one night we were on you were on stage
and you know i had the best seat in the
house every night because i'm just off
stage left so i'm basically watching his
right is actually better the stage right
i guess yeah i suppose it depends which
country we're in but i'm you know i'm
basically watching you from behind so i
have sort of the back view of you to the
crowd so i genuinely felt that every
night that i was part of the show every
night in that sense part of the audience
and i remember you said it one more time
and i thought all right i have to do
this i have to do this and that's why it
was always incredibly honest when i
would say to the crowd that that being
on tour with you for every reason that
they were there that you helped these
people change their lives that you did
that to me too but now and i think the
purpose of this conversation
which by the way if you would have said
to me 10 years ago that i'd be having
this conversation publicly first off
that i knew that i'd be married
i wouldn't have believed you that i'd
have be having kids i wouldn't have
believed you that i would be willing to
talk about this or even someone that
even someone that someone else might
look to to help map it for them i'd say
you were completely insane
um this is not really something you know
i'd rather talk about politics i'd
rather talk about the culture wars and
all of these other things this is the
political world
because we're trying to sketch out
a pathway i suppose i mean our culture
appears to have decided that
gay marriage is
well i don't know if acceptable is the
right word it's become part of the
structure of marriage itself and so now
the question is
okay what does that mean and that
certainly opens up the question
on the
child front because
i mean in in some ways marriage is the
union of two people but
in a possibly more fundamental way
it's the union of two people to provide
the foundation for children right and i
would say that's actually paramount i
mean our society tends to flip that
around and we tend to think of marriage
as something that
while you find the partner right for you
and you live happily ever after it's
well no not exactly yeah and but or
maybe maybe exactly if you
also understand that living happily ever
after
means living for other people in many
ways particularly your children
and so
and then of course that complicates the
issue on the gay marriage front because
as we're going to talk about
it's also more technically difficult to
have children if you're a homosexual
couple right so if you take just the the
marriage part first meaning that two
people are going to choose to share
their life and live together you know
share a bed et cetera et cetera
i would say culturally in america we
kind of move past that i mean trump ran
he's the first first-time president he
was on stage with a rainbow flag it was
you know and nobody cared or not i
shouldn't say nobody cared but the
enough people felt okay you let people
live the way they want to to put this
down and and move ahead
but you're right that marriage
has to do with something else otherwise
otherwise the word marriage wouldn't
mean anything it's like nobody really
cares if you live with your friend for
the rest of your life or you live with a
man or a woman you know people people do
this all the time in life and it doesn't
really matter so what really is the
purpose
of really living with somebody and
really being with somebody and sharing
your life with somebody is to build
something lasting something that
i think something that you've learned
and know and we're taught and that you
can hand that on to the next generation
and hopefully they can attain and retain
some of that permanence in your life too
right multi-generational permanent
stretching indefinitely into the future
i mean part of what marriage does
i think technically it's the
psychological equivalent of what sex
does genetically you know if
people mix
comedies
gametes gametes games
gametes
partly because to to ensure
variability and to stop the propagation
of parasites that's why we don't clone
but there's
that mixing as well
tends to
ensure
that
deviations from genetic health are
minimized
and so the same thing happens on the
psychological upfront i would say is
that each person has their own
idiosyncrasies and some of those lead
them down the garden path to terrible
places but if you're with someone else
and you have to negotiate with them
constantly
then that opens up the possibility of
you mutually modifying each other's
personalities so that you both become
healthier and that your joint existence
is a kind of can be a paragon of sorts
and then that's what the child interacts
with is that united front of the two
parents right and so you get that
longevity of view which i think helps to
mature you but you also get the
opportunity to become
more fully fledged as a psychological
being and then i think that's furthered
as well i've often thought and said this
and i do believe it's true it's very
very difficult to mature
until you have children and
there are other ways of maturing but
it's hard and the reason it's hard i
think is because
you're not mature
until someone else is more important
than you
and
it's possible that that would happen
with your wife your husband
but not like with children well i've
been thinking about that so you know
we're about to have our first child in a
month and i've been thinking about that
a lot lately like it's just something
that's constantly stirring in my head
that i feel like i've sort of gotten to
the end
of where i can get
mature in my maturation process
not that i can't change or get better at
this or that or something but i do feel
like i'm at the end of one phase right
now i really i very
much feel that and i think i'm feeling
it more and more each day as we get
closer to august 22nd which is the due
date um but you know the first part you
know you can you can take
whether it's a straight relationship or
or a gay relationship
the dance that a couple can do and the
way that they can
mature each other and love each other
and all of those things that that's one
thing but the the peace with the kids
with building this sustainable thing
it's not something that has been
proven in society yet really you know
there obviously are gay couples with
kids yeah and this has been happening
for decades but
it really is sort of unseen at the
moment which is why we wanted to have
this conversation and i was like boy i
don't even know that
in some ways i don't know that i'm the
person that's supposed to have this
conversation but maybe that's exactly
why we're both happy
you know we're trying to figure it out
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes every
interview i've ever done with him and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist both are right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell